in news that I am sure will come as a
shock to absolutely no one who's been
paying attention the Senate is set to a
quit Donald Trump in his impeachment
trial by the time you listen to today's
show by the time you watch this segment
it may already have happened it may be
soon to happen it may be happening
tomorrow now let me do something here if
you've not been following the situation
in the Senate and I actually over the
weekend I talked to some friends who
said I haven't seen anything I said
you're better off quite frankly you
might wonder why is it not shocking that
Trump is going to be found not guilty in
his impeachment trial well if you've not
been following the trial you might think
that this is a trial like a normal trial
where the the jurors the 100 senators in
the Senate will come in with an open
mind they will hear the evidence they
will welcome evidence and then they will
evaluate the facts to decide whether an
impeachment conviction of Donald Trump
makes sense or otherwise whether an
acquittal of Donald Trump makes sense
that's what you might think if you had
not been paying attention at all in
which case I envy you but that's not the
situation we have we knew in advance
that because there are 53 Republican
senators in the Senate and you need 67
senators to vote to convict in order to
get a conviction in a impeachment trial
in the Senate Republicans had made it
clear they plan to acquit in advance
we knew that Trump was going to be found
not guilty no matter what happened now
unfortunately it's even worse because
it's not just that Republican senators
decided in advance that they were going
to acquit Donald Trump but they went
through and at least pretended to be
handling this like a normal trial it's
worse than that Republicans voted on
Friday not to even hear from witnesses
firsthand witnesses while claiming for
months that the problem is we don't have
any firsthand witnesses here and this is
why the term cover-up is increasingly
being used to describe describe what is
a sham impeachment trial now Republicans
have been using the term sham not a sham
like a sham Wow the type you would use
you know it's
cloth a dishtowel that you would use to
clean things they've been using the term
sham to describe the mere fact that
Donald Trump was impeached by the house
and of course it's often projection
there was a sham here but the Sham was
that this was anything like a real trial
and in a way I know I've said before and
a lot of people don't like when I say
this that Mitch McConnell has been an
extremely valuable asset to Republicans
and one of the most effective Republican
tools and I say that not not in in the
pejorative way but a very useful tool to
Republicans you've got to hand it to
them Republicans have played this really
really well at the start of the trial
Democrats wanted to decide are we going
to have witnesses are we going to have
documents are we going to issue
subpoenas and Republicans said let's
figure that out later
of course Republicans have the majority
so they got it Republicans successfully
said let's do 64 hours of trial first 24
hours of house impeachment managers 24
hours of Trump's attorneys 16 hours of
senator questions let's do all of that
first and then we will decide about
witnesses and every time that Democrats
stood up and said I have an amendment
for the proceedings where we will decide
now about witnesses Republicans said we
already have a plan for that we're going
to do that after 64 hours of proceedings
in any other trial it would not have
been done this way in any other trial
you decide first about witnesses and
evidence so that both sides can build
their cases around the witnesses and the
documents that would be part of the
trial but Republicans control the Senate
and they got their way and then we saw
last week we talked about this during my
live streams as the 64 hours of
proceedings were starting to reach the
end Republicans started to slip in this
line that we noticed which is once we're
done with these 64 hours will decide
whether we really need to hear more and
this is it's evil genius because they
started making it about have we had
enough hours of trial when really the
issue is not do we need 64 or 84 or 104
hours of trial the issue is are there
material firsthand witnesses who could
testify and the answer
yes former national security adviser
john bolton remember republicans said
nobody here is a first-hand witness it
was a lie binman was a first-hand
witness we had others but john bolton
would unquestionably be a first-hand
witness they don't want him bolton
saying in his upcoming book and likely
would say the same thing under oath
which is donald trump personally told me
hold the aid to Ukraine until they
publicly smear Joe Biden that's a
first-hand witness they don't want it
Rudy's henchmen left Parnas he has
recordings he is now we have it by the
way a second video in which he is
meeting with Donald Trump he was putting
physical surveillance on ambassador
Murray Ivanovitch she's a first-hand
participant now we don't need to hear
him Republicans say the acquittal means
nothing but it also means everything to
the people who just want to be let off
the hook so they can vote for Trump in
November of 2020 if you complain about
know firsthand witnesses and
simultaneously block firsthand witnesses
you are not an honest actor you are not
a good faith participant so let's just
cut to the end of the story because I
think most of you know where this is
going as I've said on the show since is
it April of 2017 the Moller probe was
never going to remove Donald Trump the
25th amendment no matter how bad Trump
gets cognitively will not be used to
remove Donald Trump impeachment or
imprint as some of our angry right-wing
email or say impeachment was never going
to remove Donald Trump are you going to
remove Donald Trump is the question
because the the single and solitary way
to do it is to vote in such overwhelming
numbers in November that even election
tampering even foreign interference even
voter purges has have been happening in
a number of different states won't be
enough to get him reelected I agree with
you that the way this has gone is
disgusting and it's not really a trial
but at a certain point we've got to play
the hand that's dealt in the game that
everybody else is playing as opposed to
insisting we'd rather be playing a
different game or have a different hand
and that's the last option we have the
question in terms of the repercussions
of the impeachment acquittal is now the
one that I've been
suggesting for several weeks or months
is the acquittal going to reinvigorate
Trump support supporters who will feel
that Trump has been vindicated instead
of just being the beneficiary of a sham
trial Mitch McConnell grinning
ear-to-ear and we knew he would be
always proof something bad happened if
Mitch McConnell is happy happy by the
way Trump is tweeting vindication and
attacks on Democrats but there has been
no vindication his followers will
believe there was one and so we have to
do this thing and it starts today it
starts today with the Iowa caucuses
because you can bet your ass that the
next cover-up is going to be much worse
because there are no consequences some
people went to prison because of the
Moller probe yes
left partisan igor freeman we don't know
what's going to happen to them but in
context compared to what they've gotten
away with there have really been no
consequences the only countervailing
force here is such a crushing ly massive
defeat in November that they can't use
their dirty tricks of voter suppression
foreign interference election tampering
all that stuff that they won't be able
to use that to win and otherwise it's
over folks I mean it's it we just have
to recognize it's another four years of
this with all of the garbage that comes
with it Hillary Clinton now is saying
things publicly that are only going to
help Donald Trump which we're going to
talk about a little bit later it's a
mess so let's take step one a journey of
a thousand miles begins with one step
feel like it's very a very prescient a
proverb in the context of the Trump
administration
let's take step one tonight in Iowa go
and participate let's have a clean
caucus we'll have live coverage on
YouTube twitch and Facebook tonight as
the results come in join me and then
tomorrow we will take step two